wie viel hast du bei re wie verdient ich
frage für einen freund willkommen zu
diesem video geben werde großes vw
beantworten heute nämlich fragen die
irgendwo auf instagram nach youtube
gestellt habe und holy moly waren dass
viele und galle fragen wie sie 500
fragen wirklich und wer weiß heute mein
handy dass mir heute die frage stellen
wir ja fangen wir direkt mal an wie
sieht es aus wenn doré wie ein
reihenhaus ungefähr so
sowas ist die nächste frage was ist dein
lieblings innen da gucken wir doch mal
nach sinn sonst an meinem pc also der
fisch kinder wären wir ganz vorn mit
dabei
der ist auch ein ganz klar das gilt aber
wenn ich ehrlich bin dann ist sehr gute
hier mal gewinnst genährt das ist ja die
meisten leute findet hässlich ich finde
das auch okay bruder was ist die nächste
frage was machst du jetzt nach der zeit
als cutter bei rewe
[Musik]
vielleicht hätte dann doch lieber
bleiben sollen danke bruder kannste
tutorials machen wie man zum beispiel
videos schneidet und effekte einfügt ich
arbeite tatsächlich schon an kursen bei
mich einfach so viele leute danach
fragen und nicht generell auf mega
bockhop das leuten beizubringen ich
werde das ungefähr jeden tag zehn mal
gefragt deswegen arbeite ich gerade
daran einen schnittkurs zu machen mit
prämie pro der mal von kompletten links
nach rechts geht und wo man dann auch
richtiges geld hat wenn man den fertig
gemacht hatte der kommt ungefähr zehn
tagen raus also ablauf integriert und
checke meine instagram stories weil da
halte ich euch auf dem laufenden
wie viel hat eine teuerste kamera
gekostet das ist tatsächlich die kamera
mit carl filme und die hat zusammen mit
dem objektiv 3100 euro kostet eine
heftige investition war also das ist die
a 73 dieser eine richtig geile kamera
hat sich auf jeden fall gelohnt next
question please wie viel hast du bei
rewe verdient ich frage für einen freund
was einen sebastian helbing kenne ich
doch irgendwoher
ich bin 28 jahre alt und habe somit im
gegensatz zu den ganzen neunjährigen die
sich sonst im moment mal dass die ihr
vielleicht oder vielleicht auch nicht
wisst habe ich bei rewe freiberuflich
gearbeitet das heißt ich war nicht fest
angestellt sondern habe ebenfalls die
rechnungen raus geschrieben und wurde
deswegen also pro video bezahlt aber
daher natürlich immer um die vergleich
in den videos gebracht hat war das dann
auch immer pro monat ungefähr gleich
viel und wie viel das war also ich sag
mal so es hat auf jeden fall die sie zum
leben reicht so dass ich noch etwas
beiseite legen konnte ich habe aber
neben rewe auch noch für andere leute
gearbeitet und da habe ich auch noch mal
nicht schlecht verdient das heißt alles
in allem kann ich mich absolut nicht
beschweren ich kann euch natürlich als
nicht die exakte zahl sagen ich hoffe
dass besteht hier also es war auf jeden
fall schon ordentlich und ist auf jeden
fall auch mehr als die meisten leute als
einstiegsgehalt bekommen wenn du eine
millionen euro hättest was würdest du
kaufen ich weiß ehrlich nicht ich glaub
ich google mal so richtig teuren sachen
traumhaus weltreise gut für eine million
euro kann man eine gute weltreise machen
sport wegen gemälde alte comics gar
nicht mal so spannend tatsächlich etwas
was sagst du hast du einen kilo pompeji
sie immer der nächste frage ist vom
guten epic stone was machst du in deiner
freizeit
[Musik]
was soll ich sagen okay was faktoren
schwingt schwanz xxxx fragt was wolltest
du vor youtube machen vor youtube da
wollte ich auch schon mit ihm machen und
ganz for you tube da wollte ich maler
werden
die ananas hasserin fragt liebste dann
von deinem eigenen content oder
arbeitest du dann bei jemandem also
folgendes ich werde auf jeden fall
natürlich auch von meinem dann kommt ein
leben so mancher läuft der relativ gut
tatsächlich also ich habe jetzt so
meinen best monaten eine 2,5 millionen
klicks gemacht und in meinen schlechten
monaten so 600.000 und das ist dann
theoretisch wenn man so damit rechnen
könnte ein euro pro 1000 klickt könnte
man da schon fast hinkommt da ich aber
bei weitem kein euro pro 1000 klicks
sondern viel weniger warum auch immer
kann ich natürlich davon nicht leben ich
kann aber auch sagen dass ich ein
bisschen was beiseite gelegt habe
deswegen muss ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
auf krampf mega schnell und viel geld
verdienen wird auch ab und an noch was
machen werde aber zum beispiel auch
musik wie das machen wenn ich gerade
anfragen klick und macht momentan zum
beispiel auch was von dem fernsehsender
aber im großen und ganzen werde ich die
meisten angebote die ihr einkommen
ablehnen weil ich natürlich meine meiste
zeit in diesen kanal stärken möchte
mary roos 25 fragt wo warst du schon
überall auf der welt also ich war schon
norwegen in dänemark in sweden in der
tschechoslowakei ich war in italien ich
war in österreich in der schweiz
griechenland natürlich frankreich
belgien luxemburg spanien amerika in den
usa karibik namibia kroatien und hallen
über die man sich drüber fährt auf einer
autobahn raststätte mal so was sind
deine pläne für den sommer
also was ist noch nicht gibt machte nur
dann einen champagner bar ba-x frage
buch gibt kann die nächste frage mehr
fällt mir gerade so 1 also wenn ihr bock
habt auf einen richtig geilen kurs mit
dem wir das schneiden lehren könnte der
dauerte über zwei stunden oder so also
da ist wirklich viel drin so dann habt
ihr auf ihn war echt skill nach dem ding
dann folgt man auf instagram rein und
steckt meine story star halte ich mich
auf dem laufenden und anwender
angefangen hat dann lasst blumen daumen
nach oben da und wenn ihr mich auf diese
weise im garten möchtet dann abonniert
mich und dann sehen wir zunächst mal
wieder und macht's gut
[Musik]